so what happened to the king and the  sting podcast it's no longer oh the king  and the sting podcast yeah the the the  podcast is still going I'm just not I'm  not doing it you're Brandon cool though  yeah yeah  we just  honestly man I missed I couldn't I  didn't have enough attention really to  focus yeah like I like I like my own  podcast and we have a unique kind of  audience I think yeah and I think I  wanted to be able to I feel a lot more  in touch with this now yeah like it's  important to me yeah and it was still  important but it was just a lot to try  and juggle yeah I liked uh the Gringo  poppy actually yeah yeah yeah oh I think  uh people give Brennan so much  uh Flack and I think that's one of the  reasons I admire him in some ways yeah  is how you could withstand so much  uh disdain from people you know or fake  disdain yeah it's pretty psychotic